ah summer i thought you would never get
here is there anything better than the
warm sunshine the sounds of the waves
the feeling of the sand
uv indexes five apply more sunscreen
maybe this is a slight exaggeration but
just like my mom the nitatmo june nags
me to put on more sunscreen and get out
of the sun the uv tracking bracelet
pairs with my iphone to give me more
information about the sun exposure i'm
getting okay sure in situations like
this i don't really need to be warned to
get out of the sun or put on sunscreen
my burning eyes and my burning skin have
done that quite well no bluetooth
required but the gadget has made me more
aware of the sun exposure i'm getting
especially when it's cloudy or windy
that is when it actually works
you won't find any buttons or blinking
lights on this tracker instead nitamo
designed the june to look like a piece
of jewelry it's the first wearable i
truly haven't minded wearing all day you
can even clip it to your bathing suit or
shirt the uv sensor is embedded in the
face of the device when paired via
bluetooth with your iphone you can see
the live uv index the app will tell you
how much of your maximum daily sun
dosage you've gotten that's based on the
uv index the amount of time you've been
in the sun and your skin type it will
also alert you when you should reapply
sunscreen or when the uv index has gone
up the app suggests spf 15 for me but
dermatologists recommend a minimum of
spf 30. in part because most people
don't apply enough sunscreen to begin
with in fact i spoke to a lot of
dermatologists this week about the dune
bracelet and they all say you should put
on one full ounce of sunscreen every
time you apply that is like a full shot
glass of sunscreen every time there are
other glaring problems too the app
interface itself is confusing the
bluetooth connection drops and it only
works with the iphone also the bracelet
isn't waterproof the company says it can
get splashed and a little bit wet but
you should not go swimming with it on of
course that's pretty ironic since
you know
the june did accomplish part of its goal
it definitely made me more aware of how
much sun i was getting even when i just
went out to get a coffee but it's
complicated app and other issues stop me
from wanting to dedicate wrist space to
it even though it does look cool
ultimately i'd like uv tracking and some
of these other cool design features to
come to the wearable fitness bracelets
we're already wearing until then i'm
spending my 99 this summer on much more
sunscreen
and cool hats